le ministre nous attendons que les
recommandations du Sénat que la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Marie Mercier soit réellement prise en
compte dans le programme PHARE et
deviennent surtout effective sur le
terrain nous serons donc pas attentifs
dans les prochains mois à la mise en
œuvre de tout ce que vous avez annoncé
ce matin et répéter cet après-midi la
mobilisation ne doit pas fléchir le
Sénat vous accompagnera la sérénité de
tous nos élèves à l'école est en jeu
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
l'ordre du jour rappelle la discussion
de la proposition de loi pour une école
de la liberté de l'égalité des chances
et de la laïcité présentée par Monsieur
Max Brisson et plusieurs de ses
collègues à la demande du groupe des
Républicains dans la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Max Brisson que
nous allons appeler à nouveau
sur ce plateau
[Applaudissements]
10 minutes
pour ce faire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
Jacques
Céline coteur de cette proposition de
loi monsieur le Président de la
Commission chers collègues alors dans
les pays de l'OCDE la moyenne est de 4,9
% du PIB
5,2 du produit intérieur brut voilà ce
que la France consacre à l'éducation de
sa jeunesse première mission volume l'an
dernier
nous votion un budget de 60 milliards
d'euros et pourtant et pourtant la
performance d'autres systèmes éducatif
ne cesse de se dégrader production
d'inégalités décrochage dans les
classements internationaux lacunes dans
l'acquisition des savoirs fondamentaux
enquête et rapports nous alertes sur la
dramatique baisse du niveau en
mathématiques et en sciences ou sur les
difficultés croissantes des élèves en
lecture et en compréhension dénoncer
simple ces évaluations inquiètent un
peuple tout entier sans qu'on puisse les
emblamer année après année les parents
canon les moyens font fuir à leurs
enfants les plus mauvais établissements
l'évitement est devenu un sport national
parallèlement le nombre de candidats aux
métiers
le ministère recrute en urgence des
contractuels bombardées professeurs en
48 heures et affecté dans
l'établissement plus difficile le métier
de moins en moins attractif et nous
doutons monsieur le ministre que la
seule revalorisation des salaires aussi
nécessaire qu'elle soit remplaces une
réponse structurelle l'éducation
nationale est en crise pourtant pourtant
l'attachement à notre école demeure son
redressement est espéré s'il y a des
divergences c'est sur des réponses à
apporter pour la majorité des acteurs
elles sont essentiellement financières
entre 2012 et 2017 11% de hausse du
budget de l'éducation entre 2017 et
21% d'augmentation c'était une nécessité
assurément les résultats ont-ils été à
la hauteur certainement pas depuis trop
longtemps
crédit et moyens supplémentaires sont
les remèdes exclusifs à la dégradation
de notre école ne nous y trompons pas il
masque l'impuissance l'impuissance à
réformé un système trop vertical trop
uniforme et oubliez des particularités
on dépense beaucoup alors qu'on ne
repense jamais en profondeur
l'organisation de notre système éducatif
impuissance à laquelle la rue de
Grenelle a trop souvent répondu par plus
de contrôle plus de procédures plus de
circulaire plus de mermise dans la vie
des établissements et par une GRH qui
infinie c'est coupé de la réalité des
conditions d'exercice du métier
d'enseignant ces dernières années au
rare lettre ministériel qui dans le
passé fixait un cadre et des objectifs
généraux ont succédé la valanche des
circulaires la multiplication des
injonctions
l'enchevêtrement des contrats d'objectif
et disons-le le plaisir d'un verbiage
plus ridicule que précieux alors qu'en
Europe la tendance en général conduisait
à donner plus de souffle plus
d'autonomie au système d'éducation en
France verticalité centralisation
uniformisation épuise désormais toutes
les initiatives et découragent les
meilleurs idées tout cela bien sûr au
nom des grands principes d'unités
d'égalité alors que notre système
scolaire produit ségrégation et
inégalité le cœur de cette proposition
de loi et dans d'en finir avec cette
asphyxie bureaucratique et d'engager une
rupture avec le conservatisme ambiant
arc-bouté sur deux Maxime qui font
Flores au ministère on l'a déjà fait et
c'est impossible pourtant rapport après
rapport la Cour des comptes nous le dit
les systèmes scolaires les plus
performants sont ceux qui donnent le
plus de place à chaque établissement
fédérant à ce niveau la communauté
éducative autour d'un projet commun qui
encourage les enseignants à être
novateurs et améliorer leur performance
et celles de leurs collègues tout est
dit ce sont bien la liberté et
l'autonomie qui font défaut à l'homme de
ce constat je vous propose donc de poser
les fondations d'une plus grande
autonomie des établissements scolaires à
travers la création expérimentale sur la
base du volontariat des établissements
publics autonomes d'éducation ces
établissements auront la possibilité de
contractualiser avec les réacteurs et
les collectivités terroristoriales leur
organisation pédagogique les dispositifs
d'accompagnement des élèves
l'affectation des personnels la location
et l'utilisation des moyens le
recrutement des élèves une
contractualisation non pas pilotée par
le haut encadré corps se t adeptes du
copier-coller mais bel et bien initié
par les équipes pédagogiques pour
s'adapter aux réalités de chaque
établissement bref le contraire de ce
qui a été initié jusqu'à lors et qui se
poursuit aujourd'hui en effet Monsieur
le Ministre l'école du futur l'école
faisons là ensemble le fond pédagogique
pour l'innovation demeure malgré le
discours présidentiel sur l'autonomie
marquée au fer rouge du pilotage par le
haut ces initiatives sont à leur tour
ont pétrées par une application
restrictive en serrée Rabou gris parfois
même en porte-à-faux avec l'objectif
initial en dépit de l'intention sincère
de donner plus de souplesse et de
souffle aux établissements à l'inverse
l'expérimentation des établissements
publics autonomes redonnera elle toute
sa place tout son sens tous ces moyens
au projet pédagogique d'un établissement
tout en continuant de l'inscrire dans un
cadre national qui énerve depuis deux
siècles notre système éducatif
l'expérimentation s'appuiera également
sur les contrats de mission qui
permettront d'aller d'aérer les
caractères des professeurs de rompre
avec leur linéarité et donc pour
l'institution de soutenir l'envie que
beaucoup ont d'innové de changer bref
l'envie de véritablement servi mes chers
collègues nous sommes dans cette hémices
tous partisans sensibles à la
spécificité des territoires et chacun
d'entre nous c'est d'expérience
qu'aucune école aucun collège aucun
lycée ne se ressemble qui mieux que le
professeur s'est adapté ses
enseignements aux élèves qui mieux que
le directeur le principal ou le
proviseur peut définir les besoins de
l'établissement dont il a la
responsabilité voilà l'esprit de cette
expérimentation donner une plus grande
liberté au collège aux écoles au lycée
au directeur au chef d'établissements et
aux professeurs c'est incontournable
pour promouvoir le mérite et les
qualités des chances je sais que le
débat clivant et alors l'autre mot
qu'elle se texte apporte un début de
réponse et celui de l'acquisition des
savoirs fondamentaux elle va essayer
parce que l'école s'éparpille le temps
effectif de leur enseignement se réduit
alors que les programmes se densifient
bigarré d'une multitude d'éducation a de
l'institution scolaire il est désormais
moins attendu l'instruction qu'une
réponse multiple défi sociétaux bien
loin de l'asile inviolable ou les
querelles des hommes ne pénètre pas
qu'appelait de ses vœux janzés pour
répondre à cette baisse du Divo je vous
propose donc de créer un service public
de soutien scolaire et de généraliser
l'accès de tous les élèves à des cours
de soutien plus de démarcation entre
ceux dont les familles ont les
ressources pour payer ses cours et ceux
qui ne les ont pas le service public
soutien scolaire s'appuiera entre autres
sur des professeurs volontaires y
compris retraités réunis sous la forme
d'une réserve éducative
la question de la formation des
professeurs doit également être posée
enseigné dans le premier ou le son degré
ce n'est pas le même métier la formation
ne peut être identique cette proposition
de loi vous propose de dissocier la
formation des enseignants du premier et
du second degré il ne s'agit pour moi ni
de revenir sur la masterisation ni sur
le lien avec l'université mais d'arrêter
de se payer de mots et de redonner enfin
la mer à l'éducation nationale dans la
formation des professeurs des écoles en
dernier lieu mes chers collègues vous le
savez
nous sommes vigilants sur la question de
la laïcité l'école doit-on demeurer cet
outil de rassemblement fondé sur une
stricte laïcité c'est le sens des
dispositions sur la neutralité des
accompagnateurs scolaires et sur le port
d'une tenue d'établissement renforçant
le sentiment d'appartenance et le vivre
ensemble j'espère que sur ces sujets
comme sur les autres nos débats seront à
la hauteur des enjeux conscient que ceux
qui se jouent dans les établissements
loin des postures dogmatiques pour
terminer je veux saluer très
chaleureusement notre rapporteur Jacques
gros Perrin pour son travail et la
mission pied de ce texte amender lors de
son passage en commission mes chers
collègues nous avons certaines pas les
mêmes solutions à proposer les débats
sur les nombreux amendements en des
moyens j'ai aimé les vœux qui soient
féconds et fertile car notre école le
mérite soyez au moins rassuré d'une
chose les propositions qui figurent dans
ce texte reposent sur des convictions
fortes et sur une passion immodérée pour
l'école de la République
collègue
monsieur Masson vous faites un rappel au
règlement
j'avais demandé la parole tout à l'heure
en application de l'article 44 alinéa 6
du règlement puis je crois que vous ne
m'avez pas vu mais je vous remercie
madame la Présidente de m'avoir permis
de m'exprimer lorsque nous avons débattu
de ce texte en commission il y a deux
articles qui manifestement ont paru les
plus importants et qui ont été l'objet
du plus grand nombre de d'intervention
et surtout des interventions les plus
passionnées et je crois que c'est vrai
ce sont les articles sur la laïcité sur
les articles fondamentaux de ce texte de
loi et je suis quand même quelque peu
surpris que les deux articles les plus
importants étaient placés à la fin
complètement à la fin du texte parce que
quand on présente une proposition de loi
mise à part pour la loi sur les
retraites ou l'article 7 avait été déjà
bien décalé par le gouvernement mais
l'exemple du gouvernement sur les
retraites ne doit pas être repris je
dirais que c'est le mauvais exemple mais
quand il y a des articles importants
c'est quand même normal qu'on les place
en tête des débats et en début de loi et
donc
pour pallier ce problème je voudrais en
application de l'article 44 à lignée
assis demander une priorité pour les
articles 10 et 11 et pour qu'il soit
traités en premier dans l'ordre de nos
débats voilà madame la Présidente merci
chers collègues actes tes données de
votre rappel au règlement ce que je vous
propose c'est d'inscrire votre demande
de priorité après les prises de parole
du rapporteur Jacques gros Perrin et la
réponse l'intervention de Monsieur le
Ministre si ça vous convient parfait
monsieur le rapporteur paroles vous est
donné pour 5 minutes 10 minutes pardon
j'ai tenté
vous avez tenté madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues ce texte part d'un constat
l'institution scolaire est en souffrance
nombreux sont non concitoyens être
inquiets un Français sur deux pense que
l'école fonctionne mal et les deux tiers
des Français sont pessimistes sur leur
avenir cette proportion atteint 80% chez
les enseignants c'est la traduit un
mal-être profond l'école de la confiance
a céder la place à l'école de la
défiance pourquoi parce que l'école
n'arrive pas à atteindre les objectifs
que lui assigne la nation en premier
lieu la France reste l'un des pays où
l'origine sociale des élèves
conditionnent le plus leur parcours
scolaire
malgré les moyens importants en faveur
de l'éducation prioritaire les écarts
entre les élèves scolarisés en Rep ou
réplus et ce scolarisé hors de ces
réseaux varie peu la politique sur
laquelle est bâti l'éducation
prioritaire introduit également une
dichotomie des moyens entre les
établissements relevant de celle-ci et
ceux qui n'en font pas partie
or 70% des élèves socialement
défavorisés ne sont pas scolarisés en
Rep cela crée parfois un sentiment
d'abandon pour tous ces élèves et pour
toute la communauté pédagogique
concernée
l'école ne semble plus être capable de
transmettre les savoirs fondamentaux les
élèves français de ses mains sont sur
représentés parmi les élèves européens
les plus faibles en mathématiques ou en
sciences les évaluations
intergénérationnelles mais également en
lumière une baisse de la maîtrise et
savoir fondamentaux en 40 ans sur une
même dictée les élèves de CM2 de 2021
font significativement plus de fautes
que leurs prédécesseurs de 1987 à ce
moment là près de 80% près de 30% des
élèves faisaient 25 erreurs font 25
erreurs alors qu'il n'était que 7% en
troisième cause de défiance l'éducation
nationale elle a du mal à se déployer
une politique nationale qui deviennent
compte de la diversité des territoires
le rapport de nos collègues Laurent
Laffont et Jean-Yves roux sur les
nouveaux territoires de l'éducation a
mis en lumière l'absence pendant
longtemps de la donnée ruralité dans les
statistiques de l'éducation nationale
cela conduit une politique scolaire
rurale par défaut or les parcours
scolaires PostC collègues collège et
post-bac d'une partie des jeunes ruraux
sont marqués par des écarts à la moyenne
voire des difficultés d'ampleur
comparables à celles qui caractérise les
élèves de l'éducation prioritaire ne
l'oublions pas plus d'un Français sur
cinq âgés de moins de 20 ans vit
aujourd'hui dans un territoire rural
monsieur le ministre votre circulaire de
rentrer en juin 2022 pro une école
engagée pour l'excellence l'égalité et
le bien-être mon groupe partage les
mêmes objectifs les moyens de les
atteindre en revanche diverses cette
proposition de loi porte notre vision de
l'école je tiens d'ailleurs à remercier
mon cher collègue Max Brisson l'auteur
de ce texte il doit permettre au Sénat
de débattre avec vous monsieur le
ministre et avec l'ensemble du groupe
politique projet contre projet de
l'avenir de l'école les nombreux
amendements le montrent les coller une
priorité partagée pour chacun de nos
groupes ce texte se structure autour de
quatre axes il souhaite tout d'abord
renforcer l'autonomie des établissements
scolaires
aujourd'hui l'uniformité nationale
formelle sa commode de l'argile de
traitement des élèves la politique
éducative centralisée descendante en
provenance du ministère n'arrive pas à
répondre aux besoins des élèves du
territoire
l'article 1er de la proposition de loi
ouvre la voie une expérimentation elle
permet aux écoles et aux établissements
scolaires volontaires de contractualiser
avec le recteur pour accroître leur
autonomie les collectivités concernées
peuvent faire également partie du
contrat le texte prévoit pour les écoles
qui souhaiteraient participer à cette
expérimentation d'acquérir au préalable
statut d’établissement public c'est
pourquoi chacun ici connaît bien sûr le
lien fort qui nuit la commune à son
école il faudra répondre à l'inquiétude
des élus locaux la Commission a rendu
nécessaire l'accord préalable des
conseils municipaux ou intercommunaux
lorsque la compétence scolaire a été
transformée avant tout changement de
statut à l'école l'article 2 confère ou
directeur de l'école une autorité
hiérarchique sur les enseignants notre
commission a souhaité limiter ce
dispositif aux écoles à partir d'une
certaine taille le seuil de 9 classes
dans l'école me semble intéressant cela
concernerait environ 20% des écoles
publiques
aujourd'hui des écoles accueillent plus
d'élèves que certains collèges dans
lequel les chevilles établissements
disposent eux de cette autorité
hiérarchique en revanche il nous a
semblé opportun à ce stade de conserver
pour les écoles plus petites qui ont des
équipes pédagogiques plus restreintes la
seule autorité fonctionnelle pour les
directeurs d'école j'en profite monsieur
le ministre pour vous demander quand
seront publiés les décrets d'application
de la loi react beauté il a quelques
mois la proposition de loi vise
également assurer l'égalité des chances
entre les élèves pour cela elle crée un
service public de soutien scolaire qui
pourra s'appuyer sur la réserver
éducative
plusieurs amendements de la Commission
ont permis de préciser les conditions de
participation à ce service public en
termes de diplôme de probité et de
neutralité ce texte renforce la
politique éducative en faveur des
territoires ruraux plutôt qu'un
copier-coller aux icônes et aux
établissements scolaires situés dans une
zone de revitalisation rurale des
dispositifs qui existent en éducation
prioritaire nous préférons créer des
territoires ruraux a besoin éducatifs
particuliers pourquoi ce choix la
commission parce que les zones de
revitalisation rurale sont un dispositif
fiscal qui arrive à chezance fin
décembre 2023 mais parce qu'aussi un
déploiement automatique des dispositifs
de l'éducation prioritaire dans les
territoires ruraux à peu de sens je
pense par exemple ou dédoublement des
classes de grande section CE1 au final
comme l'a montré le rapport de Pierre
Mathiot et d'Ariana Zemma la principale
problématique des élèves des territoires
ruraux et que l'orientation de
l'autocensure et de l'égalité des
chances de la poursuite des études
plutôt dans le secondaire nos collègues
Max Brisson Annick Billon et
Marie-Pierre Monnier dans leur bilan des
mesures éducatives du précédent
quinquennat ont montré combien la
réforme du lycée était difficile à
mettre en place dans les lycées de
petites tailles l'article 9 prévoit un
accord du conseil municipal avant la
fermeture d'une case dans une commune
rurale monsieur le ministre nous avons
tenu vos propos et ceux de la première
ministre sur une plus ruée annualité de
la classe scolaire et une meilleure
concertation avec les élus locaux enfin
cette prévisibilité plus réelle est
demandée par les locaux depuis de
nombreuses années la commission de la
culture et le Sénat seront
particulièrement attentifs à la mise en
oeuvre de cette mesure troisième axe de
ce texte l'amélioration de la
transmission des savoirs fondamentaux en
réformant la formation des enseignants
du premier degré
ce texte propose de transformer à des
écoles supérieures du professeur à des
écoles sous tutelle du ministre
d'éducation nationale la formation des
enseignants du premier degré enseigner
dans le premier degré demande des
compétences spécifiques en termes de
pluridisciplinarité de transmission des
savoir-faire classes à des élèves du
primaire et différentes de faire court à
des collégiens ou à des lycéens de
manière générale je me réjouis que ce
texte soit l'occasion de débattre avec
vous des modalités de recrutement et de
formation des enseignants
la Commission a souhaité sécuriser les
jeunes préparants au sein de ces
nouvelles écoles au concours
d'enseignants du 1er degré et faciliter
leur réorientation en cas d'échec au
cours ou d'abandon de la formation enfin
le texte souhaite encourager le
développement d'un sentiment
d'appartenance dans les établissements
c'est un thème cher à notre collègue
Céline Boulley il veut également
réinformer l'importance de la laïcité à
l'école notamment lors des sorties
scolaires celles-ci sont une projection
de la classe hors les murs d'autres
thématiques relatives à l'organisation
du système scolaire nous paraît
importante à débattre dans le cadre de
cette proposition de loi je pense à la
question des jardins d'enfants
ces derniers peuvent à titre
dérogatoires et uniquement jusqu'à la
rentrée 2023 2024 prendre en charge
l'instruction des enfants de 3 à 6 ans
déjà lors de l'examen de la loi pour une
école de la confiance nous avions
protesté surtout les bancs de cette
assemblée contre la fin déjà d'un enfant
comme alternative reconnue à la
maternelle nous le comprenons toujours
pas ce choix du gouvernement aussi la
Commission propose de pérenniser au-delà
de la rentrée 2023 2024 cette
possibilité d'instruction des trois six
ans par des jardins d'enfants qui
existaient avant l'entrée en Viker de la
loi pour une école de la confiance à
l'initiative de notre collègue Olivier
Pacaud nous avons également introduit un
article relatif à la bivalence un
enseignant du secondaire introduit un
enseignant du secondaire volontaire
pourrait enseigner dans deux matières
bien évidemment il bénéficierait d'une
formation spécifique la bivalence offre
de nouvelles perspectives de carrière
surtout elle permet de limiter des
affectations de personnels partagés
entre plusieurs établissements et une
meilleure intégration au sein de
l'équipe pédagogique de l'établissement
mes chers collègues ce texte veut
résolument ambitieux afin de changer en
profondeur l'école il témoigne également
de la volonté du Sénat de continuer à
faire de l'éducation la première
priorité de la nation je vous remercie
merci si monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
papendent l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
madame la Présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires culturelles et de
l'éducation monsieur le rapporteur
Jacques Perrin monsieur le sénateur Max
Brisson
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
cette proposition de loi témoigne de
l'intérêt que la chambre haute marque à
la politique publique d'éducation et je
tiens à vous en remercier votre
proposition de loi traite de sujets à la
fois structurant et d'une grande
actualité pour l'éducation nationale et
donc pour l'ensemble de la nation la
gouvernance des écoles et des
établissements la formation des
professeurs l'accompagnement aux
apprentissages des élèves les conditions
de la continuité du service public de
l'éducation dans les territoires voilà
des questions essentielles nous
partageons de nombreux constats mais nos
solutions pourront nous allons le voir
ne pas être les mêmes
sur la question de l'autonomie des
écoles et des établissements d'abord
j'observe que votre proposition existe
assez largement dans les faits pour le
second degré en effet les collèges et
les lycées sont des établissements
publics autonomes et contractualise avec
l'autorité académique certes il en va
différemment des écoles qui n'ont pas la
personnalité juridique pour autant je ne
suis pas certain que nos maires soient
prêts à renoncer à cette compétence
patrimoniale de l'échelon communale
vieille de près de 200 ans puisqu'à
l'issue puisqu'ici pardon de la loi
Guizot du 28 juin 1833 cette loi imposée
au maire d'entretenir dans leur commune
une école et dilogée un ou plusieurs
instituteurs afin d'instruire tous les
enfants
j'ai vu que vous avez avancé en
commission sur ce sujet et il ne me
semble pas opportun en l'état d'aligner
le fonctionnement de nos écoles sur les
établissements du second degré il ne
faut pas je pense laisser croire à nos
élus que nous les écarterions de
décisions importantes qui concernent les
enfants de leur commune
au passage je me permets de rappeler mon
attachement à faire vivre les
communautés éducatives locales via
notamment la démarche entreprise par le
Président de la République dans le cadre
du Conseil national de la refondation
ne vous méprenez pas cependant sur la
portée de mon propos je ne suis
nullement en train de vous dire que le
gouvernement n'est pas ouvert à une
évolution de la gouvernance du premier
degré en témoigne la loi relak de
décembre 2021 mais il faut avancer
progressivement si l'on souhaite voir
prospérer ces réformes pour répondre à
votre question monsieur le sénateur les
décrets seront prêts pour la rentrée ils
ont été soumis aux organisations
syndicales il y a dix jours il passeront
au CSA le 16 mai
c'est pourquoi je défends l'autorité
fonctionnelle des directeurs d'écoles
qui donnent à ces derniers le rôle de
pilote de son école de leur école tout
en conservant l'esprit d'un travail
collectif entre tous les professeurs de
l'école c'est un marqueur culturel fort
de notre école primaire
de la même façon j'ai engagé avec ma
collègue Sylvie Retailleau ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche une réflexion pour que nos
professeurs des écoles soient mieux
armés et formés pour répondre aux
exigences des apprentissages là encore
il me semble que nous ne différencons
pas substantiellement sur l'objectif
j'ai d'ailleurs plusieurs fois devant
vous eu l'occasion de m'exprimer en ce
sens mais je ne saurais souscrire en
l'état tout à fait à votre proposition
qui risquerait d'écarter les professeurs
d'une formation universitaire et de
l'obtention du diplôme du Master
quant à l'accompagnement des élèves non
là encore nous partageons l'objectif
d'un soutien scolaire à tout élève qui
en éprouve le besoin c'est dans ce sens
que je poursuis la politique entamée par
mon prédécesseur et c'est dans ce sens
que j'entends conduire la transformation
du collège aujourd'hui le collège n'est
pas suffisamment en capacité de remédier
aux principales difficultés scolaires
des élèves le lutter contre les
inégalités et de cultiver
l'excellence des élèves c'est dans ce
sens que la classe de 6e sera
transformée l'année prochaine afin que
les fragilités des élèves puissent être
corrigés c'est dans ce sens que je
rendrai dès la prochaine rentrée
scolaire le dispositif devoir fait
obligatoire afin que chaque élève puisse
être au-delà des heures de classe
soutenues dans ses apprentissages
accompagnés pour réviser s'entraîner et
fixer les acquis vu en classe
cette égalité des chances mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à laquelle je
viens de faire référence doit exister
dans tous les territoires y compris en
effet en ruralité vous le savez avec la
première ministre lors de notre
déplacement dans la Nièvre il y a
quelques jours nous avons annoncé des
mesures qui ne sont pas si éloignées de
vos propositions mais il faut bien
avouer que maintenir contre vents et
marées et contre la réalité des
évolutions démographiques des classes
ouvertes n'est pas pédagogiquement
viable mon devoir en tant que ministre
de l'éducation nationale et d'assurer
l'accès à l'enseignement à tous partout
sur le territoire mais pas à n'importe
quelle condition
plus rianualité des moyens instance de
dialogue préfet d'azen élu locaux pour
coordonner l'action publique
valorisation des regroupements
intercommunaux pédagogiques sont autant
de propositions qu'attendent les
territoires les élus les parents les
élèves et vous j'espère mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs puisque vous
avez souvent évoqué ces questions avec
moi
à une solution égalitaire qui
consisterait à geler les moyens partout
nous préférons une solution équitable
équilibrée qui prennent en compte
l'éloignement la qualité d'enseignement
la Vie pédagogique en pluri annualité
nous devons mettre fin aux incohérences
qui opposent l'État dans son rôle
d'aménageurs du territoire à l'état qui
organise l'instruction de nos enfants
les deux sont intimement liés car
l'école s'il doit être impérativement
accessible pour tous nos enfants doit
être aussi un lieu de vie pédagogique
qui garantit la réussite de nos élèves
c'est pourquoi nous devons mener avec
tous les acteurs élus agents de l'État
un travail de dentelle afin que
l'organisation de l'école puisse
répondre aux particularités de chacun
des territoires
sur la question de l'application de la
loi de 2004 aux parents accompagnateurs
je ne vous surprendrai pas en vous
indiquant que de manière constante tous
les gouvernements se sont opposés à
cette disposition je rappelle que les
parents ont l'occurrence n'agissent pas
en qualité d'agent de l'État le Conseil
d'État c'est déjà prolongé sur ce sujet
les parents accompagnateurs ne sont pas
soumis au principe de neutralité mais
sont bien évidemment interdits de tout
prosélytisme
deux surcroît je ne pense pas
qu’éloigner les parents de l'école soit
souhaitable tout au contraire
sur l'uniforme et j'en terminerai par là
pour que nous puissions échanger et ce
sera évidemment avec intérêt et plaisir
c'est une possibilité qui existe déjà en
Outremer les établissements qui l'ont
souhaité l'ont inscrit à leur règlement
intérieur le gouvernement est opposé à
une obligation nationale qui ne règle ni
le sujet du harcèlement ni les
différences sociales et encore moins les
atteintes à la laïcité l'uniforme serait
immédiatement contourné par différents
accessoires je ne fais donc je ne veux
donc pas uniformiser les élèves je
souhaite qu'ils comprennent et qu'ils
adhèrent aux règles de vie des
établissements et au-delà aux valeurs et
aux principes de la République c'est par
l'instruction il a pédagogie que notre
école y parviendra je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
conformément à l'article 44 alinéa 6 du
règlement je suis saisie comme vous
l'avez entendu tout à l'heure par
Monsieur Jean-Louis Masson d'une demande
de priorité d'examen des articles 10 et
11 afin qu'il soit examinés avant
l'article premier aucune explication de
vote n'est admise quelle est la vie de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
je pense que ce texte le coeur du texte
c'est avant tout on l'a dit la ruralité
c'est la formation des enseignants c'est
l'expérimentation sur l'autonomie des
enseignants c'est le vivre ensemble vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure donc je pense
qu'il n'est pas utile et il faut
examiner ce texte avec les articles à la
suite les uns des autres
la vie du gouvernement
même avis madame la Présidente
je mets donc aux voix cette demande de
priorité avec deux avis défavorables qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cette demande n'est pas
adoptée dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Monique
de Marco du groupe des écologistes pour
5 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier le groupe les
républicains d'avoir inscrit à l'ordre
du jour cette proposition de loi qui
porte une institution républicaine
capitale pour les vivre ensemble
on le sait l'école est un sujet de
clivage politique important et ce texte
ne mérite de proposer très clairement
une autre vision inspirée de la réforme
opérée en 2010 au Royaume-Uni et
évidemment le consensus serait difficile
à trouver
si nous pouvons rejoindre une partie des
constats justifiant cette initiative
parlementaire nous souhaitons nuancer le
regard critique porté sur la performance
globale je cite entre guillemets
médiocres du système éducatif français
il faut tout de suite rappeler en effet
que des évaluations internationales
auxquelles il est fait référence ne
porte pas sur l'intégralité des missions
d'évoluer à l'école on les retrouve
énumérés à l'article 4 de votre
proposition
j'en cite quelques-unes seulement
apprentissage d'un socle commun de
connaissance protection de
l'environnement enfin intégration des
élèves en situation de handicap lutte
contre les discriminations prévention de
leur radicalisation et laïcité laïcité
et encore laïcité
on le voit bien depuis sa fondation
l'école de la République est devenue le
rempart de tous les mots de la société
il n'y a affronté toute les crises et ce
dans des conditions de travail que l'on
connaît
je rappelle ainsi qu'en 2020 les élèves
sont en moyenne 18,4 par enseignants
dans l'enseignement primaire en France
compte 13,6 dans l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne
en remettant en perspective les
résultats des enquêtes de comparaison
internationale avec l'ensemble de ces
missions il y avait des moyens à louer
on peut considérer que l'on ne sentir
pas si mal
pendant des décennies le métier
d'enseignant c'est complexifier sans
reverbilisation substantielle de
rémunération pour ceux qui exercent mais
aussi de reconnaissance
monsieur le ministre certains des
déclarations que vous avez faites devant
la salle nationale pour réconsidérer
avec certaines propositions d'une
collègues et les républicains annuel
annuels ruralité
s'agit-il d'une initiative partagée ou
un test monsieur le ministre allez-vous
inscrire ce texte à l'Assemblée
nationale puisque le gouvernement a
amender ce texte suite à mon sens serait
un signe
après les années Blanquer il me semble
absolument prioritaire de restaurer
l'enseigne la confiance des enseignants
dans l'institution la dépression figure
parmi les premières maladies
professionnelles des enseignants
nous proposions pour cela de créer une
communauté enseignante plus unie du
primaire au secondaire en y associant
les aesh
il faut selon nous multiplier les
trajectoires de carrière et améliorer
les perspectives professionnelles des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
moins bien traitées
nous souhaitions également discuter de
la possibilité d'un système de tutorat
qui permette aux enseignants de tous
niveaux et de toute fonction d'obtenir
un soutien bienveillant tout au long de
leur carrière
après la censure de l'article 40 pour
ses aménagements gagés il ne resterait
rien de nous propositions et nous ne
pouvons que nous opposer par exemple à
la création des écoles supérieures du
professorat
je reste donc très opposé au système
d'automne d'autonomie des écoles prévues
aux articles 1 2 et 3 de la proposition
de loi et au système de
contractualisation
qui a dit d'autres inscrire dans ses
contrats que le contrat républicain de
donner à chaque enfant une égale chance
d'épanouissement intellectuel
la question de la mixité sociale est
insuffisamment traitée
l'existence difficulté je rappelle que
dans le secondaire les REP plus
concentrent les populations les plus
défavorisées et ces sujets
nécessiteraient un véhicule législatif à
part entière
enfin après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
nous semblait essentielle de préserver
la vie scolaire en ne réactivant pas
incessamment les polémiques autour du
principe de laïcité nous proposerons la
suppression des articles 10 et 11
à l'heure où le ministère n'est pas en
mesure de garantir des remplacements
d'assurer des recrutements ni de
formation continue de qualité qui
répondent aux besoins des personnels
quel est le sens d'un tel projet en
conclusion cette proposition de loi qui
oublie nos langues régionales
menacent le faible équilibre de
l'éducation nationale
accélèrerait la privatisation aurait un
coût considérable à la charge des
familles elle creuserait les inégalités
entre établissements
parce que nous souhaitons une école
coopérative et citoyenne un service
public juste et accueillant pour toutes
et tous nous devrons pas cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
la parole est à présent à notre collègue
monsieur Julien barjoton du groupe RDPI
et vous avez 6 minutes chers collègues
merci dans la précédente monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur alors
quand on fait une proposition de loi au
Sénat en général on a deux choix
on fait une proposition de loi qu'on
espère mener à bout
consensuel ou avec des convergences
alors là on aurait pu faire par exemple
une loi sur les écoles dans la ruralité
ou une loi sur la formation des
enseignants où il y a un deuxième choix
celui que vous avez retenu qui est de
faire une proposition de loi vaste qui
retranscrit un programme politique c'est
noble c'est vous savez qu'elle ne
prospérera pas vous savez qu'elle ne
prospère pas vous l'avez dit vous-même
d'ailleurs c'est une proposition de loi
qui se veut clivante vous avez annoncé
la couleur si j'ose dire à partir de là
évidemment elle ouvre beaucoup de choses
mais comme elle ouvre beaucoup de choses
sur l'école mais partout et ben il y a
eu plein d'amendements sur parcoursup
les aesh la formation continue de nos
collègues d'union centrist de
l'éducation sexuelle à l'école
évidemment puisque c'est une loi qui
prétend embrasser l'ensemble mais qui ne
le fait pas et donc ça ouvrait la porte
à cela c'est un peu dommage je pense
qu'on aurait pu avancer ensemble sur
certains sujets précis
du coup elle a aussi pour conséquence de
revenir sur certains débats récents donc
elle revient ça a été dit sur la
neutralité pour les accompagnants
scolaires sur également l'enseignement
en famille et puis également sur le port
de l'uniforme à l'école je note
d'ailleurs que l'Union centriste une
proposition loi d'une collègue de
l'Union centriste vise en supprimer
cette article c'est bien que là aussi
vous avez tellement clivé que finalement
vous avez clivé aussi au sein de la
majorité sénatoriale et elle l'autre
conséquence de cette loi c'est que du
coup alors que vous êtes parfois
critique là-dessus elle n'attend pas les
évaluations ou les concertations pour
procéder à des propositions hors parfois
le Sénat dit il faudrait quand même
d'abord évaluer les dispositifs et
concerter c'est le cas par exemple sur
l'autorité fonctionnelle de la loi RIAC
convient de voter ou sur l'autonomie il
y a une expérimentation en cours
d'autonomie pédagogique des
établissements il y a une
expérimentation à Marseille on pourrait
attendre d'avoir un peu les résultats du
lancement ces propositions avant de d'y
revenir et d'ailleurs notre rapporteur
dans sa sagesse s'est senti obligé de
restreindre légèrement les dispositifs
dans les deux cas puisqu'il a restreint
à l'autorité fonctionnelle à certaines
écoles et qu'il a également restreint la
l'autonomie en prévoyant puisqu'il avait
été oublié peut-être d'associer quand
même davantage les élus locaux ce qui
prouve bien là aussi que c'est une loi
qui veut peut-être trop trop embrassée
et puis elle arrive dans un timing
particulier le ministre l'a dit il y a
un plan qui a annoncé sur les écoles
rurales et ça il y a aussi le Sénat qui
a lancé une mission d'information sur
l'autonomie des établissements peut-être
aurait-il fallu attendre que il y ait
que non mais vous êtes dans cette
mission d'information donc vous aurez pu
attendre vous-même les conclusions de
vos propres de vos propres travaux on a
l'impression quand même que cette
proposition de loi cherche à Prée jalons
après jalon tous les sujets et d'une
façon même s'il y a des choses
intéressantes parfois précipiter et un
peu brutal pour employer les termes et
puis elle ne répond pas à son objet vous
dites que ces lois vont pour la liberté
égalité des chances il y a quand même
peu de dispositifs sur l'égalité des
chances où est la mixité sociale dans ce
texte où est oui il y a un article sur
le soutien scolaire et d'ailleurs j'ai
nous ferons des propositions c'est un
sujet intéressant mais au-delà de ça la
mixité sociale dans l'urbain vous avez
fait le regard mais du coup vous avez
pas fait l'urbain etc etc donc
finalement et il y a d'autres sujets qui
ne sont pas abordés le privé et nos
collègues du coup dépose une série
d'amendements qui viennent montrer
finalement que elle ne correspond pas à
son objet je voudrais juste rappeler
quand même si si je ne le fais pas vous
m'en voudriez parce que personne ne le
ferait que le dédoublement de classe
dans les repérer plus en CP et CE1 c'est
300 000 élèves et que ça va atteindre
les grandes sections de mat le système
devoir fait les résultats c'est 10
points 10 points d'amélioration sur les
mathématiques et le français dans les
zones concernées l'école
inclusive 430 000 élèves porteurs de
handicap contre 320 000 au début 2017
les cordées de la réussite 200000 élèves
sont ainsi accompagnés de la quatrième à
la terminale bref il faut quand même
aussi rappeler un certain nombre de
dispositifs ce qui n'empêche pas de les
compléter de proposer des améliorations
mais il est bon aussi de repartir de ce
qui existe vous le voyez ce loi cette
loi cette proposition de loi elle a une
vocation politique d'ouvrir un débat je
dirais parfois d'ouvrir des polémiques
alors que je pense que l'école mérite de
la confiance et de l'efficacité c'est
dans ce sens que nous entrerons dans le
débat vous avez voulu en faire un sujet
clivant il faudrait aussi se dire
comment se débat peut faire de l'école
un lieu de rassemblement merci beaucoup
merci la parole est à présent à notre
collègue madame Marie-Pierre Monnier du
groupe socialiste pour 9 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 10 avril
1870 Jules Ferry prononçait les mots
suivants dans l'enceinte du Palais
Bourbon ma prétention est de vous
montrer que l'égalité d'éducation n'est
pas une autopie que c'est un principe
qu'endroit elle est incontestable et
qu'en pratique cette utopie apparente
est dans l'ordre des choses possibles
c'est d'abord à cette exigence d'égalité
que nous devons nous attacher quand nous
évoquons l'école de la République pas à
celle de la performance trop souvent
portée au nu comme si l'école était
d'une entreprise la proposition de loi
que nous examinons aujourd'hui est un
condensé des propositions mises en avant
par la droite depuis des décennies pour
transformer une institution qu'elle
estime défaillante autonomie des
établissements scolaires renforcés
jusqu'à l'extrême autorité hiérarchique
des directeurs d'école remise en cause
du cadre de la fonction publique pour
les recrutements enseignants uniforme
obligatoire je souhaite en premier lieu
rappeler que loin des discours à la mist
sur le sujet la dernière étude publiée
en 2022 établi à 74% le niveau de
confiance de la population dans
l'institution scolaire bien sûr tout ne
va pas bien mais nous considérons pour
notre parc c'est dans notre école a
besoin c'est de moyen à la hauteur pour
fonctionner dans de bonnes conditions et
non pas de telle mesure qui ont vocation
à la faire basculer dans une logique
libérale et concurrentielle bien loin
des principes républicains j'entends
déjà mes collègues du côté droit de
cette hémicycle me répondre que des
moyens on en donne déjà bien assez mais
je souhaiterais à ce titre partager
quelques éléments de comparaison à
l'échelle européenne d'abord dans ce
rapport consacré à l'Europe de
l'éducation publiée en décembre 2022 la
Direction de l'évaluation de la
prospective et de la performance pointe
que la France est le pays de l'Union
européenne dont les effectifs par classe
sont les plus élevés
les élèves scolarisés en élémentaires en
France sont en moyenne 22 par classe
contre 19,3 dans le reste de l'UE au
collège effectivement moyen approche 26
élèves alors que la moyenne européenne
est située sous la barre des 21 la
France est aussi l'un des pays de l'UE
où les enseignants doivent assurer un
nombre d'heures de cours parmi les plus
élevés et ce alors que leur salaire est
inférieur à la moyenne européenne
l'évolution de nos dépenses en matière
d'éducation mérite également d'être
scruté avec plus d'attention dans un
contexte où l'on entend dire et quel
serait un puissant fond la dépense
intérieure de l'éducation a atteint un
pic de 7,7 du PIB au milieu des années
90 elle évolue aujourd'hui de moyenne en
moyenne autour de
7%, depuis les années 80 l'État s'est
progressivement désengagé tes dépenses
au profit des collectivités
territoriales dont la part dans les
dépenses d'éducation et passer de 14%
1980 23% en 2021 j'ajoute que quitte à
nous poser des questions sur
l'efficacité du budget alloué à
l'éducation nationale nous pourrions
nous interroger sur les sommes
attribuées spécifiquement à
l'enseignement privé sous contrat
financé à 73% par de l'argent public
est-il bien normal que dans une ville
comme Paris les établissements privés
disposent de plus d'heures
d'enseignements rapportés au nombre
d'élèves que leur homologue public pour
en revenir au détail des articles que
contient ce texte plusieurs constituent
pour notre groupe une ligne rouge nous
aurons à cœur de défendre tout au long
de cet examen leur suppression l'article
1 qui prévoit l'expérimentation d'une
autonomie renforcée des établissements
scolaires du premier second degré va à
l'encontre de notre vision républicaine
de l'école qui doit être la même pour
tous les élèves sur l'ensemble du
territoire et répondre au même programme
et objectifs le cadre expérimental dans
lequel il s'inscrit et par ailleurs
fragile juridiquement il ne me semble
pas possible que les établissements
publics autonomes de l'éducation soit
créée pour une durée temporaire article
2 instaure une autorité hiérarchique
pour les directeurs d'écoles certes
circonscrits suivant le nombre de
classes à la suite de l'examen en
commission nous avions déjà pas eu
l'occasion de l'affirmer lors de
l'examen de la loi relak nous sommes
attachés au fonctionnement collégial des
écoles du 1er degré celui des pères
parmi les pères nous reviendrons
d'ailleurs par voie d'amendement sur la
notion d'autorité fonctionnelle votée
alors qui introduit une première brèche
sur le sujet la mise en place des
contrats de mission entre recteurs et
enseignants proposés à l'article 3
s'inscrit dans un cadre dérogatoire au
droit commun de la fonction publique qui
n'est pas acceptable un tel dispositif
qui impactera l'ensemble du bassin de
recrutement bien au-delà des seuls
établissements concernés et ne résoudra
d'ailleurs en rien le manque
d'attractivité de certains
établissements ou certains territoires
l'article 10 étant le principe de
neutralité et l'interdiction du port
ostensible de signes religieux aux
participants occasionnel du service
public de l'éducation
mon groupe c'est toujours opposé à une
telle extension de ses obligations aux
accompagnateurs et accompagnatrices de
sortie scolaires
j'ajouterai que le sujet de la laïcité à
l'école mérite une autre approche visant
une meilleure appropriation et adhésion
de nos élèves à ce principe fondamental
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
dans le cadre de la formation des
enseignants
d'autres dispositions de ce texte moins
clivantes on le mérite de soulever des
problématiques pertinentes même si nos
différents parfois sur les réponses
apportées
ainsi nous considérons que la formation
initiale des enseignants du premier
degré peut être revu et améliorer dans
son déroulement il ne nous semble pas
aux portes de mettre fin à la culture
professionnelle commune entre premier et
second degré que permettent les INP et
d'éloigner la formation des enseignants
du premier degré du monde universitaire
et de la Recherche
l'article 6 pose les jalons d'un service
public de soutien scolaire c'est un
signal positif qui répond à un besoin
social fort qui ne peut être laisser à
la main du privé
nous aurions souhaité l'encadrer
davantage afin de garantir la qualité de
l'accompagnement proposé aux élèves au
regard des exigences et de la continuité
dans les apprentissages nécessaires nous
considérons en effet qu'il doit être
pour le second degré assuré uniquement
par des professeurs et ceux en
l'intégrant à leurs heures de service
nos amants demain en ce sens ont
malheureusement été jugés irrecevable en
raison des charges supplémentaires
engendrées il est vrai que tout bon
service public nécessite un
investissement de la part de l'État
l'article 7 qui prévoit la mise en place
d'une réserve éducative pour nourrir ce
service public nous paraît redondant par
rapport à la réserve citoyenne de
l'éducation nationale déjà existante
dont il conviendrait plutôt de dresser
le bilan l'article 8 fortement remanie
en commission interroge sur les
difficultés propres élèves scolarisés en
milieu rural si son périmètre et sa
portée sont devenus floues il a le
mérite d'aborder un sujet rarement
évoqué et pourtant crucial nous
partageons la préoccupation exprimée par
l'article 10 dans l'ensemble de nos
territoires ruraux les alertes se sont
multipliées concernant les fermetures de
classe prévues à la prochaine rentrée
dans la Drôme nous comptons plus de 40
fermetures de classe et les plus
douloureuses sont des communes rurales
je ne peux que rejoindre mes collègues
qui regrettent ces fermetures en raison
de l'application d'une logique purement
comptable je je répète les choix fait au
PLF ont des conséquences j'espère
pouvoir donc compter sur eux lors du
prochain vote pour revenir sur les
suppressions de postes enseignants
opérer ces dernières années en ce qui
concerne l'article 11 qui prévoit
l'obligation d'une tenue vestimentaire
uniforme nous considérons qu'il n'est
pas la bonne réponse à apporter aux
inégalités sociales et scolaires si nous
souhaitons nous attaquer sincèrement à
ces sujets la mixité sociale constitue
la vraie porte d'entrée si je me réjouis
toujours de l'opportunité d'un temps de
débat au sein de notre hémicycle sur
l'école ce texte me laisse toutefois un
goût amer car il me semble que ces
propositions ne sont pas à la hauteur
des enjeux auxquels est aujourd'hui
confronté notre école de la République
pourtant essentiel pour nos enfants et
l'avenir de notre pays si nous
souhaitons réellement être dans une
approche moins verticale et plus proche
du terrain nous devrions en premier lieu
écouter les préoccupations des
personnels qui s'efforcent de la faire
vivre au quotidien
merci chers collègues
je t'en prie la parole est à présent à
Madame Céline Brulin du groupe
communiste pour 5 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le seul et
maigre mérite de cette proposition de
loi et de montrer que de véritables
projets de société sous tendent la
vision de l'école dans notre pays pour
notre part nous portons une vision
clairement de gauche celle d'une école
ayant pour l'objectif l'égalité des
chances et la justice sociale celle
d'une école qui offre le plus haut
niveau de connaissance à des enfants qui
deviendront ainsi quelle que soit leur
parcours ultérieur des citoyens et des
travailleurs conscients et responsables
celle d'une école qui apporte plus à
ceux dont le patrimoine culturel et
moindre ce qui est intrinsèquement lié à
la condition sociale
et le temps n'émous pas cette conviction
au contraire face au bouleversement
technologique et scientifique qui peut
résumer l'éducation un socle minimal de
connaissances face aux enjeux
démocratiques qui peut raisonnablement
considérer que nos jeunes doivent être
plus formés à l'obéissance qu'apprendre
à développer leur esprit critique et
leur capacité à se forger une opinion
solide éclairée par l'histoire par
exemple et bien les auteurs de cette
proposition de loi dont la vision est
clairement de droite et même
réactionnaire la blouse devenant
l'uniforme
l'autorité devenant hiérarchique le
recentrage sur le lit écrire compter
frappant jusqu'à la formation des
enseignants la main invisible du marché
son cortège de concurrence et l'idée
selon laquelle seule ce qui serait privé
serait efficace ont également pris
toutes leurs places dans cette
proposition de loi même mes chers
collègues vous n'êtes pas à une
contradiction près car votre proposition
consiste de fait à créer une forme de
séparatisme alors qu'il faudrait
renforcer l'école de la République de
même vous dites vouloir libérer les
énergies susciter les innovations alors
que vous vous acharnez à encadrer les
pratiques professionnelles des
enseignants jusque dans les moindres
détails même à titre expérimental la
contractualisation que vous envisagez
conduirait inévitablement à une école à
la carte d'un service public national
motivé par une obligation de moyens à
louer par l'État nous basculent nous
basculerions vers une myriade d'école
sur le modèle des écoles privées
soumises à des objectifs particuliers
qui conditionneraient programme moyen
horaires et recrutement des enseignants
a sorti de votre obsession d'une
réduction massive de la dépense publique
alors qu'il faut considérer l'éducation
comme un investissement dans l'avenir
cela ne pourrait conduire qu'à une mise
en concurrence des établissements ainsi
que des disciplines mais la France ne
veut pas plus d'écoles à la carte que de
Républic à la carte contre addiction
toujours vous écartez la question des
moyens comme réponse au besoin de
renforcer l'école de la République en
pointant par exemple l'éducation
prioritaire pour finalement la
revendiquer en ruralité ou alors vous
considérez que les sorties scolaires
sont des temps de classe hors les murs
au seul motif de contrecarrer la liberté
religieuse des parents de confession
musulmane pour les autres ça vous gêne
beaucoup moins mais vous refusez
systématiquement nos propositions pour
qu'à ce même titre elle soit encadrée
par des personnels pédagogiques et en
même temps plutôt que de faire du
soutien scolaire un objectif de
l'éducation nationale avec des moyens de
rattrapage des dispositifs
individualisés vous entendez le laisser
dans les mains d'une réserve éducative
inévitablement cette mission pèsera sur
les collectivités territoriales tout
particulièrement celle qui parce que
leurs habitants rencontrent davantage de
difficultés sociales culturelles et
scolaires en font déjà beaucoup plus que
d'autres en matière éducative vous
prétendus remèdes sont finalement pires
que le mal depuis 1989 l'autonomie des
établissements publics locaux
d'enseignement ne cessent de croître
cela a-t-il permis de résorber les
inégalités absolument pas la plus
récente réforme celle du lycée conduite
au nom de cette volonté d'offrir des
marges de choix et de la liberté les
renforcent au contraire vous le savez
vous qui comme moi avait dans vos
départements des lycées offrant tous les
enseignements de spécialité ou presque
quand d'autres se contentent du minimum
les uns étant plutôt situés dans
l'hypercentre des grandes métropoles les
autres se trouvant plutôt dans les
quartiers populaires et les zones
rurales pensez-vous vraiment que c'est
en faisant porter la responsabilité de
l'ensemble de l'institution sur les
agents de première ligne qu'on
parviendra à faire face à la crise de
recrutement des enseignants que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui poser la
question c'est d'y répondre quand on
comptera de mission censé amener les
enseignants les plus expérimentés dans
les zones les plus difficiles leur échec
risque d'être aussi patent que celui du
dispositif éclair d'autant que le
mouvement
est dangereuse et nous la combattrons
comme il se doit merci
la parole est à présent à notre collègue
madame la Présidente Annick billon du
groupe Union centriste pour 8 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission je voudrais tout d'abord
remercier l'auteur du texte Max Brisson
Jacques gros Perrin également le
rapporteur pour le travail précis et
riche qui nous donne l'occasion d'avoir
un débat de fond sur l'éducation
ce texte témoigne toute la tension que
vous portez que nous portons à
l'éducation nationale et la volonté
d'élever notre école nos élèves nos
enseignants
nous en avons besoin
en effet alors que les dépenses en
matière d'éducation sont supérieures à
la moyenne des pays de l'OCDE le système
éducatif français peine à produire des
résultats satisfaisants l'école ne joue
plus son rôle d'ascenseur social l'école
ne lisse plus ne collier riche plus les
inégalités pire elle les creuse parfois
sur le niveau des élèves l'étude
internationale teams 2019 permet de
constater que les élèves français de CM1
sont sur représentés parmi les élèves
européens les plus faibles au lieu de
25% attendus dans le quartile inférieur
ils sont 45% en mathématiques et 41% en
sciences
15% des élèves français soient insur7 ne
maîtrise pas les compétences
élémentaires en mathématiques alors
qu'ils sont seulement 6% au niveau
européen
en janvier 2023 la Cour des comptes
publiait un rapport mobilisé la
communauté éducative autour du projet
d'établissement le bilan des
égalités du système éducatif les
rapports sur la mixité scolaire dans les
établissements tout comme les analyses
des résultats aux examens nationaux
démontra à quel point
l'Université nationale peut s'accommoder
de larges inégalités le silence soudain
m'a perturbé le brouhaha finalement
était
utile tout à l'heure
merci
l'institution scolaire est en souffrance
et de nombreuses interrogations
persistent sur sa capacité à répondre
aux objectifs qui lui sont assignés
selon leur apport de notre collègue
Jacques gros Perrin plus d'un Français
sur deux et trois enseignants sur quatre
pensent que l'école fonctionne mal deux
Français sur trois et huit enseignants
sur 10 sont pessimistes sur l'avenir de
l'école lors de notre rapport sur le
bilan des mesures éducatifs du
quinquennat avec mes colères mes
collègues Marie-Pierre Monnier et Max
Brisson nous avions déjà tiré le signal
d'alarme notamment sur la crise
d'attractivité que connaît le métier
d'enseignant appelé il y a encore
quelques années le plus beau métier du
monde
lorsque nous avions rendu nos
conclusions près d'un enseignant sur
quatre se demandait s'il n'aurait pas dû
choisir une autre orientation
professionnelle le constat est rude et
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
ce vœu une réponse à cette problématique
il propose de faire évoluer des
dispositions sur de nombreux sujets avec
pour objectif sinon pour ambition de
résoudre les difficultés de l'école et
donner plus de liberté aux équipes
éducatives par exemple il propose que
l'autorité fonctionnelle des directeurs
d'établissements de plus d'un certain
nombre de classes soient transformés en
autorité hiérarchique
cela permettra à l'école de mieux
s'adapter à ses besoins spécifiques les
contrats de missions proposées à
l'article 3 du texte permettront aux
enseignants de donner plus de souplesse
à l'heure ou à l'heure avec un S
affectation et de permettre aux
établissements de répondre à des besoins
qui leur sont précis la formation des
enseignants est également abordée la PPL
prévoit de séparer la formation des
professeurs du second degré de celle de
leurs collègues du premier degré ceci
afin de mieux préparer ces derniers aux
apprentissages des savoirs fondamentaux
nous allons également l'amélioration et
la meilleure prise en compte des
collectivités territoriales avec la
redéfinition de leur rôle dans
l'élaboration des politiques relatives à
l'éducation prioritaire
certains territoires ruraux
particulièrement en zone isolées ou
subissant une crise industrielle ou
poste industrielle voient ce cumuler des
difficultés sociales qui peuvent avoir
des effets et sur le les scolaire ces
difficultés ont été renforcées par la
crise sanitaire que nous avons traversé
ce sont des territoires à besoins
spécifiques aussi nous salons la
création par le rapporteur de
territoires ruraux a besoin éducatifs
particuliers cette revendication était
d'ailleurs portée par notre commission
depuis plusieurs années le rôle des
collectivités locales est également
réaffirmée à l'article 9 du texte
celui-ci propose une co-réflexion
lorsque des fermetures de classe doivent
intervenir dans les territoires
nous nous réjouissons des améliorations
apportées en commission sur ce texte
nous avons notamment proposé qu'une
condition de diplôme soit ajoutée aux
conditions de recrutement des personnels
qui formeront la réserve éducative le
niveau baccalauréat sera requis nous
avons par ailleurs souhaité renforcer le
dispositif de formation des professeurs
du premier degré afin qu'elle soit
alignées sur la formation des
professeurs du second degré de même nous
souhaitons que les étudiants bénéficient
comme leurs homologues d'actions de
formation complétant leur formation
initiale le modèle des jardins d'enfants
va perdurer grâce à un amendement
notamment porté par le président Hervé
Marseille supprimant les dispositions de
la loi de l'école de la confiance
enfin nous avons renforcé le rôle des
collectivités locales en modifiant
l'article 9 du texte en transformant le
moratoire de 1 an initialement prévu en
une période de trois ans pendant
laquelle aucune fermeture de classe ne
pourra intervenir si les conseils
municipal se prononcent lors d'un vote
contre la fermeture de classe
pour la séance nous avons déposé un
amendement de suppression de l'article
11 qui concerne le port de l'uniforme
dans les établissements scolaires la
majorité du groupe n'est pas favorable à
une telle disposition
l'uniforme est souvent présenté comme
l'un des deux leviers à activer en
réponse aux inégalités sociales et pour
favoriser la mixité scolaire or aucune
étude ne vient confirmer ce postulat si
vous me permettez le port de l'uniforme
n'est pas forcément la réponse à la
bonne tenue de notre école le groupe
Union centriste est dans sa majorité
opposée à ce dispositif
mes chers collègues convaincus de
l'importance de ce texte le groupe Union
centriste votre a donc en sa faveur je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est à présent à Madame Esther
benbassade des non inscrits pour 3
minutes chers collègues
oui c'est la journée
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues aujourd'hui nous
discutons d'une proposition de loi
issue comme vous l'avez compris de la
droite sénatoriale pour une école de la
liberté de l'égalité des chances et de
la laïcité si l'intitulé semble être
porteur d'espoir et de renouveau le
contenu les mois ainsi dès le premier
article le ton est donné il est proposé
d'accroître l'autonomie des
établissements scolaires sous contrat
qui aurait désormais la possibilité de
recruter leurs élèves de choisir leur
organisation pédagogique et de donner
une liberté quasi totale au directeur de
l'établissement
avec ce mode de sélection des élèves
vous réduisez leurs chances à certains
d'accéder à l'établissement scolaire de
leur choix par ailleurs les inégalités
entre les cessent de s'aggraver le poids
de l'origine sociale se reflète
inévitablement dans les résultats
scolaires le système éducatif français
ne parvient plus à prendre en charge les
élèves les plus faibles selon la
dernière enquête du programme
international pour le suivi des acquis
des élèves la France est un des pays de
l'OCDE qui affiche un très grand écart
de réussite entre les enfants les plus
défavorisés et ceux
issus des familles les plus aisées et
surtout éduqué c'est un chantier sur
lequel il est urgent de travailler et
pourtant les mesures proposées sont
insuffisantes et ne semblent pas
répondre à cette impératif de réduction
des inégalités scolaires de surcroît le
texte
intègre d'autres marqueurs indélébile
dans de la droite
comme l'interdiction du port du voile
pour les accompagnatrices scolaires à
l'Artic 9 et le port obligatoire de
l'uniforme à l'article 10 encore une
fois le principe de la laïcité déformée
aujourd'hui la laïcité serait menacée
partout en France et l'école en grave
danger que ce soit dans les assiettes à
la cantine lors des sorties scolaires
dans les cours de récré ou encore à la
piscine
tout prétexte est bon pour redéfinir le
principe de laïcité à sa sauce et
encourager le marché électoral qui est
le vote de l'islamophobie cette
stigmatisation permanente ne fait que
renforcer le repli communautaire c'est
un engrenage vicieux que l'éducation
nationale devrait endiguer à force de
pédagogie de formation la laïcité de
dialogues professeurs élèves et
professeurs parents Emmanuel Macron a
déclaré le 16 mars dernier qu'il ferait
de l'école sa priorité et faire de sorte
que l'école soit ouverte à tous
émancipatrice libératrice inclusive ce
texte ne répond visiblement pas à cette
ambition je voterai contre pour un texte
qui fait des clins d'yeux à l'extrême
droite et dans le contenu et sur l'année
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent un monsieur le sénateur Bernard
fialer du groupe RDSE et vous avez 5
minutes chers collègues pour vous
exprimer rebonsoir
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le Président Monsieur l'auteur de cette
proposition
pourquoi la République n'est plus perçue
comme l'idéal qui fait rêver
parce que la promesse républicaine n'est
pas tenue aussi ne nous étonnons pas que
certains se tournent vers d'autres
promesses et celles aux emprise
idéologiques qui leur sont proposés
monsieur le ministre ici même devant
vous il y a un mois je rappelais les
vœux du président de la République la
principale injustice qui mine notre pays
demeure le déterminisme familial la trop
faible mobilité sociale et la réponse se
trouve dans l'école
vous nous aviez annoncé pour fin mars de
nouvelles dispositions d'affectation des
élèves plus équitables entre école
publique et privées qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui
cette proposition de loi pour une école
de la liberté de l'égalité des chances
et de la laïcité est une interpellation
forte au constat accablant du modèle et
éducatif français
classement internationaux catastrophique
crise de recrutement des enseignants
à l'image des déserts médicaux il ne
faudrait pas avoir se développer des
déserts de république des zones de
non-droit
les vérités scientifiques sont
contestées par des croyances révélées
les principes de la République sont
ignorés et la laïcité bafouie nous ne
pouvons pas laisser se dégrader ce pan
essentiel de notre société dont les
ressources humaines sont la principale
richesse
l'éducation devrait être la priorité de
nos investissements à quoi bon vouloir
relocaliser rien industrialiser investir
sans ressources humaines à hauteur et
épanoui
il faut également rétablir de l'autorité
une autorité scientifique indiscutable
une autorité morale affirmée et comme
marqueur l'autorité de compétences des
maîtres qui enseignent sous l'autorité
des directeurs chefs d'établissement
cette absence de hiérarchie est un des
handicaps de l'école publique par
rapport à l'école privée
de nom de l'autonomie aux établissements
l'égalité n'a jamais été l'unicite
formité ni l'unicité elle est au
contraire l'adaptation au terrain et aux
circonstances et doit pour cela ceci est
des collectivités locales mérit bien sûr
mais aussi les services médico-sociaux
des départements les régions pour
l'orientation les parents d'élèves et
l'éducation nationale avec l'école comme
chef de fil
l'expérimentation d'établissements
publics autonomes d'éducation va dans ce
sens comme la réserve éducative proposée
le périscolaire tel qu'il a été reçu
comme une contrainte précipitée par
nombre de collectivités n'est pas
partout à la hauteur de l'enjeu majeur
que constitue le temps d'accompagnement
des enfants qui ne doivent pas être
livrés aux réseaux sociaux au
désœuvrement avec les risques auxquels
on les expose
l'encadrement des enfants par une
communauté éducative doit être renforcée
combien de parents font le choix de
l'enseignement privé à cause de
l'absentéisme non remplacé
les enseignants doivent être soutenus
respectés financièrement et socialement
comme dit Jacques Perrin faire classe
dans le primaire ce n'est pas la même
chose que faire court dans le secondaire
il faut une formation spécifique et
adaptée les écoles supérieures des
professeurs des écoles qui nous sont
proposés pour succéder aux INP qui
succédaient déjà aux espèces qui
succédaient aux ufm ne serait-elle pas
que nous regretter écoles normales alors
appelons un chat un chat et revenons aux
écoles normales auxquelles d'ailleurs le
président de la République ne serait pas
hostile pour enseigner les fondamentaux
et affirmer les vérités scientifiques
qui ne peuvent plus être contestées ou
menacés ainsi que ceux qui les process
Jean-Pierre Oudin dans une enquête
récente révèle que 50% des enseignants
et particulièrement les plus jeunes
surtout censure devant les menaces et
les craintes de représailles l'humilité
du savoir est vécu comme une faiblesse
par ceux qui le contestent ne cédons
rien sur la laïcité ces principes et sur
la neutralité qu'elle exige aussi bien
sur les tenues vestimentaires des
enseignants des élèves que des
accompagnants scolaires
si la proposition d'uniforme décolle
nous semble excessive elle réaffirme
cependant qu'aucune culture aucune
expression religieuse ne peut porter
atteinte à l'émancipation et à la
liberté des femmes par exemple
le curé l'imam ou le rabbin ne peuvent
remplacer l'instituteur et je suis
heureux que nous partageions en fin tous
cette affirmation de l'école de la
République
il faut enfin revoir la participation
des communes au financement des écoles
privées dans le contexte d'augmentation
des charges de coûts de l'énergie comme
des salaires une baisse d'effectif d'une
école pour cause démographique ou de
mutation d'élèves dans le privé
renchérit automatiquement la
participation des communes elle divise
leur coût fixe par un nombre moins
d'élèves et abondent ainsi les
ressources de leurs concurrence cela
rend tout nouvel investissement
supplémentaire d'ailleurs encore plus
pénalisant les charges devraient être
divisées par le nombre de places
potentielles et non par le nombre
d'élèves effectifs je vous ai déjà
alerté sur ce sujet monsieur le ministre
bien évidemment le groupe RDSE soutient
ce cri d'alerte que nous vous adressons
pour rétablir l'excellence de l'école de
la République
merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à Madame Céline
boulet esperronier du groupe les
républicain et vous avez 7 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mes chers collègues
vu que jamais l'éducation et le pilier
fondamental de notre société le système
éducatif français fournit un
apprentissage de qualité à des millions
d'élèves chaque année malgré cela la
crise de l'école est un constat qui ne
fait plus débat perte de confiance des
familles et des élèves manque de soutien
auprès des personnels de l'Éducation
nationale crise d'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant baisse du sentiment
d'appartenance autant de manifestations
d'une institution affaiblie qui peine à
trouver un nouveau souffle
il est clair que nous devons renforcer
l'école davantage d'autonomie pour les
établissements scolaires permettrait de
mieux répondre aux besoins et aux
attentes des élèves des parents et des
enseignants cela favoriserait
l'innovation à l'expérimentation
pédagogique en donnant aux
établissements davantage de latitude
pour adapter les méthodes d'enseignement
aux caractéristiques de leurs élèves et
à leur contexte spécifique
tel quel est l'objectif de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue Max
Brisson un objectif que nous partageons
sans réserve je souhaite remercier
chaleureusement le rapporteur Jacques
Grosperrin pour l'ensemble du travail
réalisé
à l'heure où l'intégration des nouveaux
outils technologiques l'influence des
réseaux sociaux Vienne bouleverser les
rapports à l'apprentissage et à la
transmission des savoirs je suis
convaincu que nous devons concentrer nos
efforts pour contribuer à améliorer
l'égalité des chances les mots respects
autorité fierté d'appartenance altruisme
ne sont pas des mots désuets il est
temps de ressentuariser l’école autour
de ses valeurs il est temps de recentrer
l'école sur les savoirs fondamentaux
dont le premier est le savoir-être avec
pragmatisme et loin des positions
idéologiques
concernant l'article 11 de la
proposition de loi visant à rendre
obligatoire la tenue d'établissements
scolaire je crois qu'il est temps de
réévaluer le rôle de cette dernière dans
l'éducation et de la considérer sous un
nouveau jour dans l'école de 2023 ce
serait même un gage de modernité et
d'efficacité et je vais m'en expliquer
je vous précise que nous avons choisi le
terme d'établissement plutôt que celui
d'uniformes car il met en avant
l'autonomie des établissements dans la
mise en application de cette obligation
elle sera réalisée en concertation avec
les parents la communauté éducative et
les élèves en fonction des
particularités géographiques sociales et
économiques locales en somme les
spécificités des territoires si cette
question a suscité beaucoup de débats en
métropole ces dernières années je
précise que les partisans de la tenue
d'établissement à l'école républicaine
sont majoritaires en France en effet un
sondage CSA diffusé le 12 janvier 2023
évoque 60% des Français sont pour
d'ailleurs elle a fait ses preuves dans
les outre-mer la tenue d'établissement
permet de renforcer l'entraide et le
sentiment d'appartenance pourquoi ce qui
fonctionne dans le cas d'une association
ou d'une équipe sportive ne
fonctionnerait pas à plus grande échelle
par ailleurs elle sera un moyen de
préparer les élèves à la vie
professionnelle l'enfant qui franchit le
seuil de son école devient un élève et
entre dans une situation de travail la
tenue comme dans d'autres professions
aide au respect des règles en matière de
sécurité ce qui est à prendre en compte
elle minimise le risque d'éventuelles
intrusions dans l'enceinte des
établissements par ailleurs la tenue
d'établissement scolaire permet
d'évacuer la question du port de signe
ostensible d'appartenance religieuses ou
communautaire assurant une pleine
application du principe de laïcité c'est
un outil de simplification service de la
communauté éducative qui est soumise à
l'interprétation de tenue
susceptible d'être un caractère
prosélyte
monsieur le ministre là-dessus nous
avons un désaccord car nier les vertus
de la tenue obligatoire ce serait privé
les enseignants d'un outil qui les
protège
pour preuve en novembre dernier votre
ministère faisait savoir que depuis la
rentrée scolaire 2022 les atteintes à la
laïcité étaient en forte hausse sans
parler de tout celles qui ne sont pas
signalées dernier point et non des
moindres la tenue d'établissement
scolaire est une mesure sociale elle
permettra de limiter le diktat des
marques coûteuse pour les familles
pouvant conduire l'élève à l'exclusion
au raquettes et au harcèlement
concernant le financement l'état
abondera pour les familles ne disposant
pas de ressources suffisantes par le
biais de la location scolaire cette
mesure aussi pourrait profiter à nos
entreprises françaises et mettre en
avant le made in France par exemple
c'est une piste qu'à mon sens il faudra
explorer
pour conclure ma conviction est à la
tenue d'établissement est un outil
efficace bien sûr cet outil ne suffira
pas à résoudre tous les mots de l'école
elle n'en a pas la prétention bien sûr
elle n'est pas une potion magique elle
contribuera néanmoins à renforcer une
culture commune fondée sur le respect
indispensable au ciment de l'école la
majorité des acteurs de l'éducation et
des élèves que j'ai interrogés m'ont
conforté dans cette conviction et Cher
Annick billon chère Julien barjetton la
meilleure évaluation pour moi c'est la
consultation à grande échelle
concernant l'ensemble de la proposition
de loi de notre collègue Max Brisson
notre groupe vous l'avez compris la
votera car à l'ambition de proposer de
vraies solutions à des difficultés
indéniables je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Franck Menonville du groupe les
indépendants et vous avez 5 minutes
chers collègues
merci Madame la présidence monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la gravité de la crise que traverse
notre école est réelle une défiance
s'installe peu à peu le niveau
d'ensemble baisse et le métier
d'enseignant attire de moins en moins
pourtant l'école et ses enseignants sont
en première ligne pour transmettre à
notre jeunesse la grande les grandes
valeurs de la République
citoyenneté laïcité culture de
l'engagement sont au cœur des missions
de l'école acteurs majeurs de l'égalité
des chances ce contrat liant la
République et ses enfants et futurs
citoyens est aujourd'hui à renouveler
l'école a aujourd'hui besoin d'un
nouveau souffle et de nouvelles
perspectives c'est tout l'objet de cette
proposition de loi qui s'appelle à ce
vaste chantier
l'égalité des chances tout d'abord en
proposant la création d'un service
public de soutien scolaire en effet nous
constatons que c'est un vrai sujet de
fracture sociale au sein des familles
elle a d'ailleurs été exacerbée pendant
la crise sanitaire et le confinement
2020 concernant les sauveurs
fondamentaux le texte propose de réarmer
les enseignements du premier les
enseignants du premier degré en
améliorant leur formation il prévoit
aussi la création d'école supérieure du
professorat qui prépare au concours et
forment les enseignants et forment
davantage et mieux les enseignants
stagiaires cela représenterait donc une
vraie avancée pour mieux préparer les
enseignants du premier degré pour
l'apprentissage des savoirs fondamentaux
cette proposition de loi vise aussi à
accroître l'autonomie des établissements
par voie d'expérimentation il est en
effet essentiel de donner aux
établissements la capacité d'initiative
d'innovation qui s'imposent cela
participe aussi à la motivation des
enseignants et peut-être il faudrait
sans doute s'inspirer des systèmes
éducatifs des pays nordiques qui
reposent sur l'autonomie des professeurs
et celui également du Portugal qui tente
à décentraliser les processus de
recrutement et à octroyer davantage
d'autonomie aux établissements
de plus il me semble qu'il faut aller
plus loin et réformer le statut des
directeurs d'école en renforçant le rôle
et notamment dans les écoles les plus
importantes le texte n'oublie pas non
plus la ruralité et défend avec
conviction une approche différenciée en
matière scolaire les territoires ruraux
nécessitent des critères spécifiques et
adaptés à leurs défis ce texte prévoit
également qu'une décision de fermeture
de classe sera soumise à l'avis du
conseil municipal ou
des conseils intercommunaux il est
absolument essentiel d'associer
davantage les élus locaux dans ce
processus car les conséquences d'une
telle décision tant humaine que
financière sont lourdes pour les
territoires en matière de laïcité cette
loi en tant étant notamment aux
accompagnateurs le principe de
neutralité politique et religieuse lors
des sorties scolaires
la laïcité et l'un des grands principes
qui doit être réaffirmé dans l'école de
la République en 2021 l'Ifop publié un
rapport en partenariat avec la Fondation
Jean Jaurès et Charlie Hebdo quelques
mois après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
l'enquête soulignée a fait important 34
% des professeurs en réseau éducatif
prioritaire ont témoigné de
perturbations lors des cérémonies
d'hommages par ailleurs et selon le
rapport de Jean-Pierre Odin Aubin la
moitié des professeurs déclare cette
auto censurée pour éviter des incidents
avec certains élèves ces chiffres
doivent nous alerter et nous engager à
agir au plus près des difficultés dans
témoignent les enseignants et aller
soutenir dans l'exercice de leur noble
mission nous devons cesser les petits
renossements du quotidien qui font
reculer la République et son idéal mes
chers collègues ensemble le nouveau
devant engager un grand chantier pour
refonder les bases de notre école
républicaine elle doit être
petit Patrice elle doit préparer nos
enfants au défi de demain et les guider
sur les chemins ardus de la connaissance
nous devons mener une vraie réforme
structurelle pour que les établissements
disposent d'une plus grande autonomie
les équipes de plus de liberté et de
capacité d'initiative pour ainsi mieux
s'adapter aux besoins des élèves cette
proposition de loi le mérite d'en
proposer quelques premières pierres et
d'ouvrir la porte à d'autres
améliorations c'est un très bon signal
que notre assemblée s'empare de ce sujet
et qui nous tient à cœur et qui est le
moteur de l'espérance républicaine pour
tout cela je salue donc le travail de
l'auteur de cette proposition de loi Max
Brisson et de le travail bien évidemment
également du rapporteur Jacques gros
Perrin et notre groupe votera en faveur
de ce texte merci
merci
la parole est enfin Monsieur Olivier
pacaudo groupe les républicains pour 7
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur très cher collègue l'école
passionne
elle fait parfois clivée
elle peut susciter la caricature et
effectivement notre pauvre
Max Brisson caricaturé en vieux
réactionnaire c'était quand même pas
très gentil cher Céline Brulin je ne
dirai pas vous êtes une bonne cheville
rose quand même
mais
réjouissons-nous de débattre
réjouissons-nous de ne pas penser la
même chose
réjouissons-nous d'avoir des visions
différentes c'est ça la démocratie c'est
le débat et nous allons après le repas
débattre effectivement de vision
différente et de propositions pour
réinsuffler un nouvel élan à cette école
qui en attend besoin l'école c'est le
sanctuaire républicain par excellence la
République en France y est pour ainsi
dire né son idéal y a été cultivé si est
affermi et propagée à l'ensemble du
corps social chez nous l'école et la
République sont consubstantielles
hélas ce cœur battant de la République
cet organe essentiel de notre démocratie
celui-là même qui est censé insuffler
toute sa vitalité et sa cohésion à notre
société est malade
il souffle depuis il souffre pardon
depuis trop longtemps de mon nombreux
souvent nier
faute de diagnostic effectué à temps
l'affection qui ronge l'école est
devenue générale et ce sont toutes ces
fonctions qui en sont atteintes
le tableau symptomatologique si je puis
dire
de cette maladie de l'école les guerres
reluisant et pour cause là où elle
obtenait des résultats pédagogiques
excellents donnant une instruction vaste
et ferme à des générations entières de
jeunes l'école peine aujourd'hui à
inculquer à ses élèves les fondamentaux
lire écrire compter sans compter tous
ceux qui sortent du système
sans bagages ni diplôme la dégringolade
de notre pays dans les différents
classements internationaux n'en est que
l'insigne illustration cela était dit
l'école est par ailleurs devenue
l'institution ou apparaît la première
lézarde sur la cuirasse de l'autorité
la volonté de s'affranchir des règles
communes il devient légion
la figure tutélaire de l'enseignant et
méprisé or comment attendre des
générations futures qu'elles tiennent
notre état et ses lois en respect si
elles ne sont déjà plus capables d'obéir
aux enseignants censés les faire venir à
la citoyenneté
par ailleurs l'école et ça a été débattu
tout à l'heure
est devenu un lieu de souffrance et de
violence pour les élèves la cloche qui
sonne la fin de la récréation
n'interrompue la tragédie du harcèlement
scolaire devenue permanent sous sa forme
cyber brimades moqueries et autres
persécutions ne sont plus contenues par
les grilles fermées de l'école elle
chemine par les écrans colportés par les
réseaux sociaux s'insinue jusque dans
l'intimité du foyer ne laissant plus la
moindre très valeur malheureusement
victimes le tableau des pains jusqu'à
présent est déjà bien sombre mais
comment pourrait-il en aller autrement
quand les chevilles ouvrières de
l'institution scolaire sont si mal
considérées je veux bien évidemment
parler des professeurs comment exiger
deux qu'ils accomplissent ce qui
s'apparente à un véritable sacerdoce
républicain dans les conditions synaves
quand leur rémunération les classes
parmi les enseignants les moins bien
payés d'Europe quand un constantopropre
est jeté sur une profession bien souvent
ingratte et aux difficultés mal connues
les sessions de recrutement hâtives
parfois par la voix de douteuse du job
dating les concours qui comptent 2 à 3
fois moins de L'Oréal que de postes à
pourvoir sont d'autres symptômes
inquiétants de la crise dans laquelle
s'enlise notre modèle éducatif
se trouvera-t-il encore suffisamment
d'enseignants compétents et dévoués
devant nos élèves à la fin de la
décennie
enfin que dire de l'abandon des
territoires ruraux par les politiques
éducatives
si d'aucuns ont pu dire de façon
caricaturale qu'il existait une école à
deux vitesses en opposant un
enseignement public en difficulté et un
enseignement privé prisé pour avoir
conservé les qualités et vanouies du
premier alors force est de constater
qu'il existe également un enseignement
prioritaire à deux vitesses celui
choyant les quartiers de la politique de
la ville au détriment des non moins
déshérités zones rurales en politique
d'éducation comme en tout c'est encore
une fois les métropoles ou les
agglomérations et le désert français une
répartition plus équitable des
ressources de l'enseignant a prioritaire
ne seraient que justice et permettrait
surtout à l'école de retrouver certaines
des pièces mécaniques manquantes pour
relancer le fameux ascenseur social
disparu n'oublions jamais ce chiffre
édifiant et accusateur pour notre école
70% des élèves relevant de l'éducation
prioritaire en bénéficie pas
70%. depuis six ans nous annonce une
réforme de la carte de l'éducation
prioritaire qui ne vient pas or la
République c'est l'égalité des chances
partout et pour tous ce qui n'est plus
le cas face à cette situation alarmante
la présente proposition de loi en temps
prescrire un début de romaine
administrer les premiers soins sans
toutefois se contenter d'expédience s'y
a-t-elle avec courage et ambition on ne
pourra que se réjouir des mesures
qu'elle propose que ce soit la création
d'un service public de soutien scolaire
un partenariat réel avec les
collectivités pour l'établissement de la
carte scolaire une attention
particulière portée au territoire ruraux
défavorisés la possibilité pour les
professeurs d'élargir leurs horizons via
la bivalence encouragée le respect d'une
laïcité vigilante et cohérente la
volonté de séréniser le climat scolaire
par le port d'une tenue vestimentaire
commune
une opportunité mes chers amis nous est
offerte d'enrayer la maladie de l'école
de rétablir cette dernière dans la
noblesse de ses missions et la vigueur
de ses succès tâchons-nous en saisir car
c'est dans l'école d'aujourd'hui et de
demain que se forme la société du futur
et que l'égalité des droits est surtout
des chances peut prendre forme
merci chers collègues
la discussion générale est close je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h30 pour la suite de l'examen de texte
la séance est suspendue bon appétit
chers